how challenging is it for a minister in
such circumstances
it is very challenging because of course
in the education department Jillian
Keegan is partly constrained by what the
treasury is willing to fund and the view
that the prime minister is taking on pay
settlements across the whole of the
public sector so the secretary of state
is not completely free to negotiate a
deal that she she wants to deal on uh
but at the moment these strikes are
undoubtedly doing great a great deal of
damage not just you know disruption to
parents but they're also disrupting
critically the process of recovering
Children's Learning after all the
disruption during the covert pandemic
and it's really crucial that both sides
get around the negotiating table and
find a settlement that allows schools to
go back full-time and for these strikes
to come to an end but they have been
doing that and they've not got very far
um the Unions would say they need to
strike because of the state of the
education system at the moment the
education secretary will say I can only
work with what I've got eyes and this is
all I've got at the moment it's a
stalemate it's a very tough position
because both sides as you say feel that
they've got a very strong case the
government's saying we don't have much
money we've made a more generous offer
than in in previous years the unions are
rightly pointing out that their pay has
shrunk in relation to inflation over
time that the payoffer is way less than
inflation and would mean a real terms
pay cut for their members what I think
is hopeful though is if you look outside
England at what's happening in the
negotiations in Scotland and Wales where
there are office obviously separate
negotiating processes those look as if
they're now producing a settlement it
looks as if both sides are coming
together and actually they're not very
far away from the types of settlement
that have already been offered in
England and I think that what that
suggests is that although on paper it
sounds like there's a Chasm between the
unions and the government in England
there is a deal to be done and I think
both sides need to step back they need
to remove any conditions around talks
they need to get back in the negotiating
room and it may be that we need to see
some further concessions from the
government that can bring this
industrial Action Impact on kids and
their exams yeah we're coming up to the
exam season it's exactly the time that
children don't want to see this
disruption I was also talking to the the
leader of one of the big multi-academy
trusts in England that runs lots of
schools yesterday and she was pointing
out that not only is this disrupting on
the days that the strikes take place but
it's also adding to the wider attendance
problem that we've got post covered we
know that attendance in school is way
lower and what she said she's seeing is
on the day's near to strike action
attendance is also much much lower you
know if the strikes are on a Thursday
some parents and children are thinking
well why bother going on going in on a
Friday so this is actually much more
disrupting than even the days that have
been lost and given that the difference
between both sides is probably not as
big as it it looks I think there's a
deal to be done and there was a
responsibility not just on Jillian
Keegan but on the prime minister to
actually now make a deal happen okay
good to talk to you thanks again thank
you very much join us thank you